Classical optimization is a crucial step in classical quantum algorithms
like the variational quantum eigensolver or quantum machine learning.
However, often it turns out to be difficult to minimize
complicated functions in high dimensional parameters spaces.
My name is Victoria Lipinska and in this video we'll explore
classical optimization routines for classical quantum algorithms.
Optimization problems are not easy.
When the number of parameters grows, so does the number of possible
combinations of values, and it grows exponentially.
In chess, for example, there are 64 spaces
and each player has 16 pieces after each player moves a single piece,
there are 400 different positions. After two moves 72,084 positions,
around 9 million after three and around
280 billion after four moves.
If we reach only 40 moves, the number of possible positions
is estimated to be around ten to the power of 120.
Playing a perfect game would require exploring all possible
positions and this enormous growth means that going through
all positions individually is unfeasible.
This can be solved by breaking the problem into two smaller sub-problems.
First, we need to determine which setups of the chessboard
are likely to appear in future steps of our game.
We'll call this our subspace of interest.
And second, given that subspace, we must determine what move is best.
We'll call this our best move.
In this analogy, the initial search through the subspace of interest
is the analog of our classical optimization algorithm.
Once that subspace of interest is known,
a quantum algorithm is usually responsible for finding the best move,
given that subspace.
Let's start with considering just one parameter,
theta, parameterizing a cost function which we wish to optimize.
If we plot the function, say it looks something like this,
on the X-axis we have values of the parameter theta
and on the y axis there's the cost function.
Keep in mind the cost function could be an actual financial cost
we wish to minimize or as is often the case in the variational quantum
eigensolver, it could be an energy that is minimized by nature.
Our objective is to find the theta
that corresponds to the lowest cost.
We start with an initial value of theta and in every optimization step
we find a new theta that decreases the cost further.
It seems like we know pretty easily which way to proceed on the graph if we're able to see it.
But the difficulty in optimization is that we actually don't.
We only find out the cost so a tiny piece of the whole puzzle,
once we evaluate the function on the selected theta.
This is the general way optimization works.
The optimizer samples parameters theta and calculates the cost.
As you can imagine, randomly choosing the parameter theta to reconstruct
the whole topology of the function is not very efficient.
Instead, what smart optimizers do is finding
the gradient of the function in each step.
This way the optimizer knows which direction on the plot
to follow in order to find the smallest cost.
Once the gradient is zero, the algorithm terminates,
and the minimum is found.
This minimum might not be the global minimum.
It may be a local minimum,
meaning it's the smallest value of the cost function in the neighborhood
but not across the whole range of theta.
In the case of one parameter, that's certainly possible.
However, the more parameters we have,
the more complicated the function becomes.
Already, in the case of two parameters, we have a surface,
and in the case of four, we can't even draw it anymore.
Just like in the chess example, reproducing all possibilities
quickly becomes intractable.
We see that it's difficult to minimize
complicated functions in high dimensional parameter spaces.
However, to get reasonable results, we want classical optimization
routines to be both fast and accurate.
They also need to be robust to noise,
which will have significant effect in near-term quantum computers.
Classical optimization algorithms can be broadly divided
into two classes - direct search and gradient based methods.
Gradient based methods require information about the gradient
of the function during the optimization process.
This can either be computed analytically
or approximated in a finite difference calculation.
Direct search methods do not use gradient information
and use other strategies to minimize the cost function.
Some of the most commonly used optimization algorithms
in the quantum computing landscape are the following optimizers.
COBYLA stands for constrained optimization by linear approximation
and it is a gradient-free optimization algorithm.
SLSQP is sequential least squares programming,
a gradient based optimization algorithm.
It uses a stochastic perturbation vector
to simultaneously compute an approximate gradient of the cost function.
In a noiseless environment, optimizers like COBYLA
and SLSQP were found to converge faster than SPSA.
Classical optimizers have their own parameters
that you can specify for particular cases, for example, step size.
Those can typically be found in documentation related
to the specific optimizer.
I encourage you to check the references list below for a comparison
of the most up to date classical optimizers.
Let's explore one more phenomenon connected
to classical optimization of parameterized quantum circuits.
As we saw before, a vanishing gradient of the cost function can indicate
that the optimizer ended up on a plateau with no interesting features, a so-called
"barren plateau."
A barren plateau can be a result of many factors.
The gradient of the cost function corresponding to a quantum circuit
with randomly initialized parameters
decays exponentially to zero with the number of qubits.
This is because the quantum space explored by the optimizer
becomes exponentially large when the number of qubits increases.
The ways to tackle this problem include reducing the number of parameters
and therefore the dimension of the underlying space.
Another way to think of the origin of the barren plateau issue
could be the problem agnostic nature of the parameterized circuit
faced with exponentially large parameter space.
Designing a circuit in the way tailored to the considered
problem could be a good solution.
Besides the exponential parameter space that induces barren plateaus,
other physical phenomena can also generate them:
the noise and decoherence present in the quantum computing experiments,
the overall expressibility of the parameterized circuit,
or nonlocality and degree of entanglement of the cost function modeled.
It remains an active area of research to address these challenges.
Having now reviewed the principal components of VQE,
we'll summarize the algorithm in the next video.